[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you ought to know not to mess with kelly
clarkson she kept things upbeat despite
the fact that she was navigating her
high-profile divorce to estranged
husband brandon blackstock
i'm just in a different place
i think a lot of us are in a different
place after the last couple years
[Music]
christmas isn't canceled just you is the
single from the record there were so
many things that were taken from us and
like in in canceled also i think if
you've been in like a relationship that
didn't work out and it's like you're
used to these surroundings you're used
to this place that doesn't mean it's
like all run
kelly who is now considered legally
single is trying to look at the bright
side this holiday season she rocked four
classic looks for her album when
christmas comes around this record has
some songs on there that you're not used
to for christmas some are like let's
really feel all the feelings um
christmas songs
[Music]
kelly collabed with ariana grande and
chris stapleton for the project it's a
different christmas album it kind of
feels more like an album like that you
release a it like normal but then
there's like christmas sprinkled on it
but anyway i love
[Music]
[Music]
i it on my way to you
sing jennifer jennifer lopez's song on
my way is from her upcoming rom-com
marry me but the romantic in me wants to
believe that it's also about jen finding
her way back to ben affleck everybody
just finding love in 2021
you know the year started with jennifer
being engaged to alex rodriguez but once
the benefit train left the station oh
jlo hasn't looked back
[Music]
you came with the goddess
there you go
jlo was out supporting ben on the red
carpet earlier this month looking so
happy it's hard to believe how quickly
their romance was rekindled how'd it all
happen in just eight months here's et's
benefer 2.0 timeline april 30th that was
the first report that ben and jayla were
spotted spending time together then
another major clue in july when jlo
released a single and seemed to diss her
ex a-rod when things don't feel right
when when you need a change
come here
[Music]
combia el paso means change the step in
spanish but you didn't need a translator
to know something was up with ben i
think once you get to that place then
amazing things happen to you
that you would never imagine in your
life happening
again it's the best time of my life a
few weeks later on july 24th jlo made it
instagram official posting this pic of
the couple sharing a kiss in san tropez
later benifer headed to a nightclub her
music blasting in the background as he
whispered into her ear the party gave us
2002 flashbacks maybe you guys could get
a little more press for this though
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers
six weeks later on september 10th
benefits first red carpet together in 18
years at the venice film festival before
that the gili premiere this movie will
always be important in a landmark event
in my life
ben recently revealed to howard stern
that the public backlash back then was a
major factor in their split the idea
that people hate you
and they hate you together and that
being together is poison and ugly and
toxic and thing none of us want to be
part of and who would want to have them
to dinner and i got disillusioned and
angry and disappointed and felt like a
fool i was like oh i thought those
people liked me like me
all right from benefit 2.0 to kim
kardashian's divorce filing in february
the reality star asked for joint legal
and physical custody of her four
children with kanye we're also told kim
recently filed documents to be
considered legally single and to drop
wes from her name and kanye well he's
struggling with acceptance
[Music]
kanye seemed in divorce denial on the
podcast drink champs you know snl making
my wife say i divorced him on tv when i
divorced him you have to know it came
down to just one thing
his personality and i ain't never even
seen the papers we're not even divorced
they ain't no joke to me
my kids want their parents to stay
together i want us to be together she's
still my wife it ain't no it ain't no
paperwork he also called out drake i
have this conversation where drake is
like you know i know him but i was like
but you acted like you did you got bars
just like hidden hills give your wife to
chills y'all impress your wife and shake
it chill you're gonna like go and you
know
dm every single
girl in your family every single girl
around your family it's all
psychological right
kanye recreated his marriage to kim and
set himself on fire to promote his new
album but drake's certified loverboy
beat out kanye's donda in both sales and
streaming the former rivals seemed to
bury the hatchet earlier this month
performing together at a benefit concert
i guess i shouldn't forget where i came
from
as for kim well she's moved on with pete
davidson it all started on snl where kim
spoofed sister courtney and her new man
travis barker
in october he dropped to one knee to
propose the court in santa barbara
kravis made their red carpet debut at
the vmas one month earlier that's where
court and pound megan fox made some
noise for the new men in their lives new
york i need you to get extra loud for
our future baby daddies machine gun
kelly and travis parker are you guys
going to collaborate more when it comes
to your music videos in the future he's
not allowed to have other hoes in his
music video
it's the queen or no one
[Music]
love was in the air in 2021 i keep
telling everybody i like you kevin but
i'm not linking pinkies with you at all
just give me that on a loop the fact
that everybody did the dance was amazing
hey go
ahead new addition new kids on the block
made boston boy band history performing
together for the first time at the amas
i know every single step yes you do yes
i do kevin fraser and in the new year
the new kids are heading back on the
road the mixtape tour it's back y'all
and i talked to the whole crew all about
it good night everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
performing in front of all of our fans
is going to be very special after all
this time
[Music]
it feels so exciting like when we get
chills
at looking at that poster that has to be
a good sign the new kids mixtape tour
2022 is an 80s dream come true with
special guests salt and peppa in vogue
and rick astley
[Music]
it's part of my dna that song it gave me
my life that song full stop
to you know have the experience of being
invited to be a part of something so
iconic we were like what
yes
the summer tour starts may 10th in
cincinnati ohio and goes for three
months so what are their must-haves on
the road i have a pillow pet
it's a panda and his name is oreo honey
this fan
oh my god
that's pep's version of her beyonce
donald
and you can't say jenny i was gonna say
my wife
also my son my son elijah